un dur office
tu compares de nos rêves et nos espoirs
il sera un paria et le tueur en commande
ce sera un dieu pour eux
et si un enfant rêvait de devenir autre
chose que ce à quoi la société le
destinait tient enfants inspiré à
quelque chose de plus grand
mon fils était dans le bus
il a vu ceux du clark a fait
tu es la réponse si ce temps la réponse
à sommes-nous seuls dans l'univers
si je continue à faire comme si j'étais
ton fils tué mon fils je suis persuadé
que tu as été envoyés ici pour une
raison
et même si tu passes le reste dans ta
vie
tu te dois de découvrir quelle est cette
raison
comment faire pour retrouver quelqu'un
qui a passé sa vie à effacer ses traces
certains l'ont vu comme un ange gardien
outre comme un fantôme toujours un peu à
l'écart
tu donneras aux peuples de la terre un
idéal à atteindre
il se rueront sur têt pas ils trébuchent
ont ils tomberont
le moment venu
il te rejoindre dans le soleil
venu tu les aimes à accomplir des
miracles
imaginez que votre fils est à l'abri
je le rate pas
mon père croyait que si le monde
apprenait qui je t'aime
il me jetterai
il était convaincu que le monde n'était
pas prêt
et vous
que représente le s ce n'est pas un as
sur ma planète le signifie d'espoir pain
chez nous c'est un ace que diriez-vous
de succès excusez moi